hi I'm Matt Welch for reason TV so after
four years of a crappy economy of
bipartisan dissatisfaction with bailout
economics with populist revolts on the
right and the left we are seeing on
november seventh basically the exact
same government that we had on november
sixth barack obama will be President the
Republicans will run the House of
Representatives and the Democrats will
run the Senate the status quo which has
never been less popular has just been
ratified so was 2012 a big washout for
those of us who believe in limited
government no for one thing government
on the federal level is still divided
which is a good thing for those of us
who were worried about big grand
initiatives coming from Washington and
at the state level prohibitions against
same-sex marriage seemed to be falling
in Washington and Maryland and most
significantly marijuana was legalized
recreationally for everybody in
Washington Colorado this is the single
most significant step against the drug
war against drug prohibition in our
lifetime still Republicans are waking up
on Wednesday licking their wounds well
here's something to think about two of
the Senate seats that they lost were
gimmies that they should have won
richard murdoch and indiana Todd akin
and Missouri both of whom made
intemperate comments about rape and
women there is no reason in 21st century
America that a fiscal conservative must
be a social conservative as well
majorities of Americans are telling
pollsters that they don't want the
government to run their lives and they
don't want the government to run the
economy either this is a message that
all parties should take away from the
election in 2012 4recent TV I'm Matt
Welch